hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play
broforce huh everyone pop your collars
and get ready to become skip people at
your frat party you know you know how it
goes
there's a playable prototype of broforce
this game is early in production the
final version will be significantly more
awesome
well if it's anything what I've seen
already it's already pretty damn awesome
okay so the controls if you're playing
by yourself or WASD to move around and
then T is shoot why is grenade and then
U is melee so you can play like that and
right now I think I'm Rambo I'm bro bow
ooh I can shoot right through the
friggin walls hahaha that is freaking
awesome
anyway this is a game that is currently
in alpha but it reminds me a lot of
Metal Gear nope not Metal Gear I mean
Metal Slug if you ever played Metal Slug
before like I haven't gotten far into
this at all like I barely got into it
just to familiarize with myself how to
play holy crap what the hell
I'm Chuck brownness Chuck Norris Chuck
Brodus I have no idea but I'm damned do
I even have ham oh I don't think so holy
crap this is amazing
dabbe [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] thank you
very much was that Satan hey deserve to
die
holy hell this game is freakin amazing I
would recommend stop watching this like
immediately and then and then go
straight I'm crying it's oh it's so
amazing right now I can't handle it
right now okay Who am I now I'm Arnold
bros Cinna guard I'm not clever with
coming up things on the fly that's not
why I'm a gaming commentary person I am
s because of my amazing proneness in the
gameplay that I do whoa Who am I now my
bro Bruce Willis bro
Willis ah I died a Shakey's huh can't
get me huh i'm mr. t now mr. bro t Brody
I don't know ha backed up Rambo
so apparently whenever you save someone
you just switch into another character
which is kind of pretty awesome okay I
need to stop slaving around and just
start ah is kind of tough
ah I failed the mission okay so yeah
parallel I didn't do too hard that one
but that's because I was talking instead
of playing so just let me hang on a
second while I actually get into this I
don't think I wanted to have the bro the
commando and who I got whoa who is this
yes
oh hell yeah alright let's get in here
you want some can handle this huh
chubowski alrigh moving forward junior
this is just dripping with testosterone
I hope all you ladies can handle all
this testosterone going on right now
yeah Chuck Bironas what's that you
wanted to live too bad I really wish I
could stick with one character for a
long time but I gotta imagine that
there's something to saving all these
separate characters take that Satan yes
another level competing thank you
everybody for supporting me through that
last level I don't know what you did
exactly but it was good nonetheless
anyway continuing for Scooby ah I jump
right out a lot son of a [ __ ] haha son
of a monkey mutters this is not fair
alright just let me keep one long enough
to be able to kill them all I don't need
wish to kill them all can't you see we
trying to hurry you oh those suicide
bombers I thought they had bomb strapped
to their chests apparently so I can't
help but speak in a deep testosterone
Laden voice while I'm in here can I
throw a grenade down there oh I wasn't
Agron they saw all those explosions the
roof caved up above them they're like
who who that who that annoyed why'd you
probably Invicta gate that
okay BAM [ __ ] I wonder if I could be
hurt by my own thing
well apparently not sweet huh
pooja yeah hahahaha so awesome
god I so so that was Yin huh yeah
perfect yeah Adam oh I'm loving it I
don't want to save I like this guy
can I go right now damn it fine whatever
I'll stick with it I'll just keep
racking bolete probably because this is
the Alpha and I want you to test all the
characters that's whoa no way I'm Brody
I'm blade but brode ha hoo drop
suck on that [ __ ] ah it's awesome I
don't want any others none others from
now on I am only doing it ha ha ha ha I
spoke too soon fine whatever burn
[ __ ] oh you're looking the wrong way
that was a mistake
Wow yeah hello Satan we meet again yeah
burn in hell
oh yeah hmm I know I know a lot of you
can't handle what's going on here right
now because it's pretty freaking epic if
I do say my oh so myself probably the
most epic game I've ever played in my
entire life hmm cuz I loved I loved the
Metal Slug series that was like one of
my favorite arcade games to play when I
was in Korea I loved playing at the
arcade over and over and over again yes
yes ha ha ha ha ha it's so brutal I mean
they're tiny pixels but it's so brutal
nope ain't gonna get me yeah yeah oh
trying to come out of there
pick up ha yeah
how many are gonna come out of it huh
I want to want my special attack is for
this guy what whoa that's my special
attack apparently yes I look freaking
love it boom
sorry I'm like losing myself I'm not
actually doing commentary I'm just
reduced up crunching noises cuz I can't
I can't help but this thing is just aa
nike's this thing this game is just too
awesome this game is up for release on
Steam greenlight you gotta get this game
out there it's too awesome
Asha kababs it's just ah what killed me
all the way in the beginning it's hardly
fair
I already killed everybody all cuz I
didn't touch that I'm an idiot
alright let's see what else we got can I
get blade again No yeah I guess it
doesn't matter alright got it
sweet Oh yar I'll just shoot my way
through the entire level good see yep oh
there was another checkpoint up there
that I totally missed cuz I was having
too much fun being blade okay get over
there so they're up come on there we go
shoosh Oh almost done I'm gonna stick
with this one for a little bit and use
its superpower sook migrated vette whoa
almost kill myself hmm was there like
10,000 explosions behind me what the
what the hell was that oh yeah yeah yeah
suck that down [ __ ] what why you
think you got game you think you got
game against me really
oh so brutal it's so brutal of God this
game is absolutely amazing check the
link in the description if you haven't
already to play use for yourself to get
in is freaking awesome holy crap
take that doggies yeah mr. t in the
house huh you think you girl huh is this
milk ain't gettin on no plane yeah yeah
Wow
oh no the doggy got me at least I'm
exploding man I like this whoa whoa whoa
whoa puppy puppy puppy you didn't have
to go like that doggy you could have
been a good doggy
you chose to be bad sorry puppies is
just a way goes actually this this this
power is kind of unwieldy I'm gonna
switch out with it
oh no I killed him whoops I guess that
would happen damn ha
damn that's horrible I feel bad now
shooting or killing all the doggies
mission failure
alright I'm gonna cut it here just
because this is too much awesome I want
you I want to give you guys a chance to
play for yourself this is just a small
showcase from me so try it for yourself
this thing this game is freakin amazing
you have to give it a try so thank you
for all that man thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye
ah
like this
Wow
Wow
ah